[Música]
buenas
bueno voy a arrancar con mi presentación
y esto es una charla de una historia de
amor mi historia de amor con las ideas
de la libertad
y tiene tres capítulos porque en la
medida que uno va estudiando y va
profundizando en esto el romance va
surgiendo de distintas maneras lo
primero que me enamoro del capitalismo y
la libertad básicamente fue que es una
máquina de sacar gente de la pobreza que
es la máquina de la prosperidad que es
la máquina del bienestar pero claro
cuando uno avanza en esta idea se
encuentra con detractores detractores
que acusan al sistema de ser injusto
entonces el segundo momento el romance
arranca cuando uno se empieza a poner a
estudiar sobre básicamente si el sistema
es justo o no y uno lo que descubre que
no solo que es justo sino que además es
el único sistema que es justo y como si
fuera poco la tercera etapa es una etapa
estética donde claramente uno llega a
lograr percibir la superioridad estética
del capitalismo entonces lo primero que
hay que comprender es que la historia de
la humanidad es una historia donde
básicamente
siempre la condición del hombre fue la
pobreza es decir hace poco más de 200
años el 95 por ciento de la población
del planeta tierra estaba por debajo de
la línea de pobreza extrema es decir
vivían con menos de un dólar diario si
luego llegó el capitalismo sí y ahora
digamos en un mundo que tiene siete
veces más de personas porque hemos
superado los siete mil 250 millones de
habitantes si hoy las personas debajo de
la línea extrema en menos del 5%
la contracara esto es un aumento
fenomenal de la productividad si uno
toma la historia desde el año cero hasta
el año 2000 el pp y per cápita se
multiplicó por 12 9 veces sin embargo en
los años que van entre el 0 y el 1800
solamente subió 40 por ciento todo
concentrado justo después del
descubrimiento de américa hasta que
hasta que llegó el capitalismo sí que
generó la revolución industrial y a
partir de ahí si el pp y se multiplicó
por más de 9 veces
es decir y lo otro que se percibe es una
fuerte aceleración del crecimiento en el
mundo fíjense que entre el 0 y el 1800
el mundo crecía a una tasa del 0 02 por
ciento en términos per cápita durante el
siglo 19 se acelera casi 33 veces al
saltar a 0 65 en los primeros 50 años
del siglo 20 se creció al 106 en la
segunda parte al 21 y hoy el mundo crece
al 3 por ciento qué significa esto
una explosión de crecimiento una
aceleración fenomenal de crecimiento es
más si ustedes consideran que las
cuentas nacionales subestiman
prácticamente un punto 15 el crecimiento
hoy el mundo estaría creciendo cerca del
4,15 por ciento si per cápita eso
significa que a lo largo de 100 años
vamos a estar multiplicando el pp y per
cápita por 60 veces es decir que en un
siglo si vamos a estar logrando 46 veces
más de lo que logramos en toda la
historia de la humanidad y eso se
manifiesta en qué
en el ritmo del cual digamos se duplica
el pib per cápita digamos originalmente
se tardaba tres mil cuatrocientos
sesenta y seis años después en el siglo
19 ese número cayó a casi 107 después a
65 74 en la primera parte del siglo 20
en la segunda 33 35 y ahora 223 45 si
entonces dónde está la lógica de esto
qué es lo que sostiene toda esta magia
la libertad es el modelo de la libertad
es decir aquellos países que son más
libres crecen más que el doble de
aquellos que son reprimidos sí y cuál es
la consecuencia que aquellos que son más
libres tienen un pib per cápita casi 8
veces más grande que el pp y per cápita
de los países reprimidos no sólo eso
sino que además el decil más bajo de la
distribución es decir los que peor están
si ganan 11 veces más de lo que ganan
los países reprimidos y es más si
ustedes se fijan los del decil más bajo
es decir los más pobres en los países
libres
si tienen el doble de ingreso que el
ciudadano promedio si del país reprimido
pero como la distribución del ingreso
lleva un formato de una cuadra do una
luz normal eso significa que el 75% de
la población aproximadamente vive menos
que con el ingreso promedio con lo cual
acá quedaría bien claro que es mucho
mejor ser cola de león que cabeza de
ratón es decir es mejor ser el último
orejón del tarro en un país libre sí que
ser un jerarca en un país reprimido en
paz no sólo eso sino que además en los
países que son libres la pobreza es 25
veces menor sí y no sólo eso sino que
además si la gente vive más entonces
digamos de que se sostiene toda esta
lógica virtuosa son cinco instituciones
las cinco instituciones del capitalismo
y éstas van combinadas por ejemplo la
propiedad privada con los mercados
libres es decir ustedes no pueden hacer
transacciones voluntarias sino
dueño de los bienes que están transando
y como consecuencia es muy importante
que no haya intervención del estado
porque cuando supongan ustedes y podrían
ser dueños nominalmente de algo pero el
estado le dice cómo usarlo como disponer
de ellos adquiere precio eso ya dejaría
sí de ser libre por lo tanto en los
precios no estarían cumpliendo la
función que tendrían que cumplir porque
no tendrían sentido entonces digamos es
muy importante la propiedad privada para
que sean ustedes los que intercambian lo
que está en juego sí y que lo hagan
libremente porque porque eso va a
registrar un precio y eso va a ser una
señal que se va a transmitir al sistema
y el resto de los agentes de la economía
se van a coordinar respecto a ese precio
y ahí viene la tercera institución del
capitalismo que es la competencia es
decir que haya libre entrada y salida
para que para que los recursos se puedan
reasignar entre aquellos sectores donde
el precio señala que hay escasez y que
hay problemas por resolver sí y como si
todo esto fuera poco aparecen dos
instituciones más
si una es la que tiene que ver con la
división del trabajo lejos de esa
falacia del hombre de paja que se le
acusa al capitalismo que nos quiere de
todos iguales no es decir gracias a dios
somos todos distintos somos todos
desiguales y eso permite que cada uno
nos especializamos en aquello que somos
relativamente mejores algo como que se
conoce como la ley de asociación de
ricardo si eso permite si que cada uno
de nosotros nos especializamos sí y nos
veamos obligados a lo que es la quinta
institución del capitalismo que es la
cooperación social ustedes no pueden ser
exitosos en el capitalismo sin servir al
prójimo con bienes de calidad a un mejor
precio es decir ustedes podrían odiar al
otro sin embargo como su progreso
económico y su bienestar material si
depende sustancialmente de que su
producto sea elegido por el otro
lo tienen que tratar bien aunque lo
odien
es decir como decía bastiat donde entra
el comercio no entran las balas por eso
digamos no tiene sentido esa estupidez
de la teoría del robo no hay derrame
desafío es que quiera sí donde la
literatura liberal habla del derrame
jamás hablamos de esto porque a ver a
steve jobs si no se le derramaba nada
digamos a bill gates no se le derramaba
nada ni ellos tampoco fueron un derrame
de ibm dio mal que es cara plata no se
le derrama nada es decir acá se basa
todo en cooperación social y ustedes
solamente pueden triunfar satisfaciendo
las preferencias del prójimo entonces
pero me vienen después con los nórdicos
no porque el socialismo de los nórdicos
a ver vamos a ver que de los nórdicos
por ejemplo miren estos muchachos
posicionando en business y en todo lo
bien que están los nórdicos en doing
bussiness mírenlos bien que están los
nórdicos en libertad económica
miren dónde están los nórdicos en
materia de mercado laboral de regulado y
respecto del derecho de propiedad es
decir de socialismo creo que le quedaron
solamente los altos impuestos los cuales
además lo empezaron a bajar
sustancialmente por ejemplo después de
que quebraron a fines de los 80 es decir
que de socialismo sólo tiene el hombre
porque en realidad son más pro mercados
de lo que la gente se cree entonces una
vez que uno tiene esta contundente
evidencia empírica aparece el problema
de la desigualdad no porque el
capitalismo es desigual
bueno veamos en que se sostiene toda esa
patraña mentirosa si primero digamos el
problema en los socialistas que parten
de una teoría del valor que es una
teoría del valor estúpida o sea llamada
teoría del valor trabajo es como que
ustedes digamos para determinar el
precio de algo si ustedes pueden sumar
los costos es como digamos que uno
quisiera digamos producir el vino en una
sociedad entonces toma el costo de la
el costo de la botella el costo de la
etiqueta el costo del corcho le pone un
margen y con eso vende
digamos usted se le ocurre que puedo
hacer con una botella de vino de ese
gran vino en una sociedad de abstemios
bueno me imagino que estará aumentando
la producción de vaselina en este mismo
momento sí pero digamos o sea además
sería un mundo tan tonto así que además
no habría quiebras y yo creo que hay
quiebras es más la teoría de la
explotación que sale de eso es una
estupidez porque fíjense esto si hay
algo que caracteriza el progreso
tecnológico impulsado por los
empresarios es que ahorra trabajo como
está explotando los trabajadores y
utiliza tecnología que ahorra trabajo
decir para reducir la explotación acerca
digo ahora nos encontramos que la teoría
de la explotación
entonces en el fondo los trabajo los
empresarios son benefactores sociales y
me parece que los enganchen alguna
contradicción por eso digamos la teoría
económica avanzó hacia la teoría
subjetiva del valor donde digamos los
precios se determinan por las
preferencias y la escasez y a partir de
ahí surge la remuneración de los
factores la remuneración de los factores
viene dado por lo que algo que llama el
valor del producto marginal en el caso
del trabajador si sería el valor del
producto marginal del trabajo es decir
el salario que se compone de 12 m
el precio donde intervienen las
preferencias y la escasez con lo cual a
ustedes no les puede ir bien sin servir
al prójimo conviene de calidad al mejor
precio porque si no hay quiebras y el
precio cero sí y por otro lado tiene que
ver también con que con la productividad
entonces si ustedes generan algo que
sirve al mercado que sirve a la gente
que le arregla la vida a la gente y
además su productivos se van a llenar de
plata pero está bien que así sea porque
van a ser benefactores sociales entonces
eso permite ver de qué va la
distribución del ingreso en el fondo la
distribución del ingreso tiene que ver
con como ustedes lograron servir al
prójimo es decir cuán eficiente fueron
arreglando el problema a la sociedad y
cuanto más productivos sean en eso mejor
le va a ir es decir entonces pero que
hay acerca de la justicia del
capitalismo entonces sabe que que todos
los intercambios son voluntarios algo
que los que miran teoría del valor
trabajo no pueden entender por qué las
cosas valen según el trabajo que tiene
todo entonces que van a intercambiar
nada
entonces yo les voy a contar el caso de
una sociedad sí que aparece un chiquito
que juega el fútbol y la rompe toda se
llama messi sí entonces claro todos
quieren tenerlo a messi porque saben si
que si lo tienen a messi van a ganar
todo ahora cuál es el punto el punto es
que messi cuando todos lo empiezan a
demandar que dice y yo quiero más plata
a punto tal que me gustaría llevarme por
mis dos recaudaciones del estadio con lo
cual habría que estar duplicando el
precio de las entradas los únicos que
quieren pagar eso son los catalanes con
lo cual lo contrata el barcelona
entonces le pega un peludo a todos o sea
termina siendo campeón por escándalo se
le matan de risa los madrileños en el
propio madrid de toda una fiesta
ahora cuando mira la distribución del
ingreso queda arriba -messi después los
dirigentes de barcelona y los jugadores
de barcelona después todos los españoles
salvo los catalanes y por último los
catalanes alguien podría decir que eso
es injusto si todos consiguieron lo que
querían pero vamos a otras
supongo que yo subo en autobús con mi
amiga cristina que tiene fuertes valores
sociales y se sienta a mi izquierda y
entra de repente un señor con los
bolsillos repleto de dinero a eso a ella
le parece tremendamente violento injusto
entonces saca un bate de béisbol le pone
en la cabeza y dice oh me das tu dinero
o te rompo la cabeza entonces el hombre
accedió gentilmente a darle el dinero y
suponiendo que no se la gasta ni en
cartera ni en zapato ni en hoteles y
cosas por el estilo si la reparte
igualitariamente entre los que estaban
en el autobús la pregunta es ustedes
podrían decir que esa sociedad es más
justa
entonces lo que hay que ver también es
que a lo largo del tiempo la
distribución del ingreso va mejorando
miren lo que era en los 60 si en los 80
fue mucho menos desigual en los 2000
mucho menos desigual
el índice de zinc se viene cayendo
estrepitosamente y ustedes miren lo que
era la distribución del ingreso en el
2003 en el 2011 decir que con el correr
del tiempo el mundo se va haciendo más
igualitario entonces ahora nos
enfrentamos a la situación de afirmar
con todas las letras que la justicia
social es injusta porque primero
entendamos la lógica populista la lógica
populista parte básicamente de lo que es
la forma de la distribución del ingreso
si debajo del ingreso promedio vive el
75 por ciento de la población hay un
negocio electoral buenísimo que es
hablar de pobres y rico y que le vamos a
sacar a los ricos para darle a los
pobres cuando pasa eso sí el resultado
cuál es mire digamos electoralmente gar
para un montón sí porque ustedes están
hablando el 75% de la población pero lo
que hay que entender es que la torta
algo que está fijo sino que por la
teoría de la distribución ustedes ya
vieron que es un proceso dinámico que se
genera en el mercado porque si ustedes
produjeran algo que no les sirve a nadie
van a la quiebra y no sacan ningún
ingreso consecuentemente ustedes ahí lo
que tienen es que la lógica del
populismo y el socialismo lo que hace es
destrozar los incentivos hace que la
torta termine siendo más chica y que
todos terminemos siendo más pobres
de hecho digamos siempre fue un sistema
basado en generar gran cantidad de
miseria entonces digamos que decía
milton friedman de estas cosas decía que
aquella sociedad que priorice la
igualdad por encima de la libertad no va
a conseguir nada de ambas
en cambio aquellas sociedades que
prioricen la libertad por sobre la
igualdad va a conseguir mucho de las dos
cosas es más ya lo decía john stuart
mill y ambos aquellas sociedades que se
preocupan más por la igualdad que por la
libertad termina haciendo unas
sociedades saqueadores entonces acá
aparecen dos grandes logros del
liberalismo que tiene que ver con la
igualdad ante la ley si firmamos el caso
de lo que se llama la redistribución del
ingreso y en el caso de los impuestos
progresivos o sea cuando ustedes ponen
impuestos progresivos es decir aquellos
que gravan con mayor fuerza a los que
mejor sirven al prójimo conviene de
mejor calidad o mejor precio si ustedes
eso lo que implica es tratar de manera
desigual frente a la ley a la gente
castigando al exitoso con lo cual
castigan a la producción y además le
aviso que dio este mecanismo es un robo
yo porque es ni más ni menos que hacer
caridad a punta de pistola si entonces
digamos cuando ustedes caer en esto
sin lugar a dudas le va a ir mal
entonces en el fondo lo que ustedes
tienen que comprender que estamos frente
a una discusión de valores por un lado
el socialismo basado en la envidia el
odio el resentimiento la desigualdad
ante la ley el robo y por sobre todas
las cosas tratar de igualar a los que
somos desiguales consecuentemente un
sistema violento que siempre se aplicó
por la fuerza y se llevó puesto más de
100 vidas
100 millones de vidas humanas y por el
otro lado tenemos el liberalismo el
capitalismo que no es ni más ni menos
que el respeto irrestricto del proyecto
de vida del prójimo sí basado en la
propiedad privada basado en los mercados
libres basado en la poca intervención
del estado basado en la división del
trabajo basado en la cooperación social
donde se premia al ahorro donde se
aprecia el esfuerzo del trabajo sí y
todo esto sin sirviendo el prójimo
conviene de mejor calidad a un mejor
precio decir el exitoso en el
capitalismo no es ni más ni menos que un
benefactor social pero como si todo esto
fue
somos superiores estéticamente miren lo
que es new york'
miren lo que es cuba si llamo yo no
conozco gente yéndose de new york para
cuba todos que se quieren ir al maldito
capitalismo si digamos en masa sea
estéticamente hemos sido superiores
siempre como eran los edificios de la
unión soviética eran grises oscuros sin
ventanas no les daba la luz en cambio
del otro lado que teníamos teníamos al
guggenheim si tenemos las torres gemelas
si el edificio crai ser la el empire
state digamos un conjunto de bellezas si
invitamos la bikini la minifalda también
es decir miren lo que era el auto de los
rusos en nada nosotros teníamos la
ferrari el lamborghini el maserati si en
el fondo sí estamos que en una situación
donde no sólo somos superiores en lo
productivo no sólo hemos sacado millones
de personas de la pobreza no sólo es el
único sistema que es justo sino que
además son
estéticamente superiores muchas gracias
y viva la libertad trabajo
[Aplausos]